résident deuxième invité politique
l'autre bout de l'échiquier monsieur
robert hue monsieur bonsoir bien alors
je suppose que vous ne pensez pas comme
monsieur giscard d'estaing est ce que
vous pensez vous de votre côté qu'on est
vraiment passé là aujourd'hui peut-être
une crise sociale a une vraie d'un
véritable crise politique
vous savez ce que des millions et
millions de français disent actuellement
expriment actuellement ils disent une
chose simple ils disent il faut retirer
le plan juppé et il faut négocier c'est
très simple il y a une grande question
sociale qu'est posée les français
veulent la négociation il faut bien
reconnaître textuellement monsieur juppé
s'obstine à être sourd et je voudrais
dire que évidemment il y a des problèmes
de société qui sont posées vous savez
dans ce mouvement les gens se parlent
ils parlent de l'avenir de leurs enfants
il parle de l'avenir du pays sur toutes
ces questions évidemment il y à des
réflexions qui sont portés mais je
répète il faut absolument que monsieur
juppé entendre ce qui se passe
actuellement vous dites il faut retirer
le plan juppé mais vous n'êtes pas
contre toute réforme de la sécurité
sociale
mais certainement pas il faut absolument
réformer la sécurité sociale d'ailleurs
nous avons des propositions concrètes
pour réformer la la sécurité sociale
nous nous disons que je vais les résumés
1 nous pensons qu'il faut taxer les
revenus financiers au niveau
actuellement des de la taxation de
l'année cotisations des salaires ça
rapporterait actuellement 167 milliards
c'est la première mesure la deuxième
mesure c'est que nous pensons qu'il faut
riou moduler les cotisations patronales
en fonction de de l'effort qui est fait
en matière d'emploi de croissance par
l'entreprise voilà des propositions
constructives j'ajoute à cela qu'il faut
naturellement relancer la croissance et
il faut la relance et par l'emploi il
faut la relance et par les salaires
d'ailleurs une des propositions fortes
que j'ai fait dans la campagne
présidentielle me semble complètement
d'actualité ils font relancer l'aller
les salaires je pense qu'une
augmentation de mille francs minimum des
salaires tous les salaires de moins de
15000 francs relancerait les choses dans
ce pays monsieur qui vous met là
que vous pensez que l'on doit continuer
à faire la grève et négocier pendant la
grève comme le disait hier soir ici mais
monsieur blondel ou est ce que vous
pensez qu'une certaine faune façon on
peut faire confiance au gouvernement
désormais arrêter la grève et discuter
mais il faut que le mouvement se
poursuivre puisque actuellement monsieur
juppé reste sourd monsieur juppé des les
les français ne comprennent pas mes
propositions c'est lui qui ne comprend
pas les français voilà la réalité il
faut aujourd'hui c'est simple il ne
s'agit pas d'attendre plusieurs jours il
doit négocier il faut qu'il retire son
plan et qu'ils négocient je crois que
c'est extrêmement simple c'est ce que
disent les françaises et les français
vous savez les françaises et les
français en ont assez que depuis quinze
ans on le rabâche toujours la même chose
qu'on les traite de laon pour les traite
avec arrogance qu'il ya au niveau de
l'état une des ddd docteur je sais tout
qu'ils se décident de tout qui font tout
et qui ne tiennent pas compte de ce que
disent les français et ça c'est
insupportable ces mêmes gens sortent des
mêmes écoles ils sont dans les mêmes
conseils d'administration tout ça ça ne
va pas c'est ce que disent aujourd'hui
les français il faut écouter la france
surveille je remercie